[Música]
al menos 30 muertos y miles de
damnificados ha dejado la tormenta
tropical yo está en su paso por
centroamérica y el caribe como huracán
el segundo en dos semanas yo te dejo
inundaciones derrumbes falta de
electricidad y daños considerables en
viviendas las víctimas fatales podrían
aumentar a medida que los rescatistas
llegan a comunidades aisladas
las muertes por ccoo y 19 siguen en
aumento en estados unidos este miércoles
superó las 250.000 víctimas fatales en
el país y en tan sólo una semana
registró un millón de nuevos casos
mientras tanto en nueva york' se cierra
nuevamente a partir de hoy las escuelas
públicas para contener el aumento de
contagios enlazamos con nuestra
corresponsal
el secretario de estado de eeuu mike com
visita hoy la región de los altos del
golán territorio ocupado por israel
desde 1967 y al visitar se agote en su
gira por la región es el primer
secretario estadounidense en una colonia
israelí en cisjordania donde defendió su
legalidad
hola como estan buenos dias en américa
latina y a todos ustedes que nos siguen
por la señal de france 24 mi nombre es
alan austria sean bienvenidos al menos
30 personas han fallecido a causa de la
tormenta y yo está que aunque se disipó
en centroamérica desde ayer el centro
nacional de huracanes de eeuu advierte
del peligro de fuertes lluvias a su paso
yo te deja devastación en una región
empobrecida e impactada hace dos semanas
por eta y por la pandemia del total de
fallecidos 18 se reportan en nicaragua
14 en onu de honduras 2 en el
archipiélago colombiano de san andrés
providencia y santa catalina 2 en
guatemala uno en panamá y otro en el
salvador las lluvias causadas por yota
azotan también el sur de belice y pueden
resultar en inundaciones repentinas así
lo advierte el centro nacional de
huracanes yo está allá deja
desbordamientos en extensas regiones
desde que tocó tierra el lunes como
huracán categoría 5 la máxima en la
escala saffir simpson nuestro
corresponsal en nicaragua jorge hurtado
hizo un recorrido por uno de los lugares
donde yo te causó más destrucción
veamos
pese a que yo te impacto en el caribe
nicaragüense fue aquí en el sur
específicamente departamentos como
managua carazo y rivas en donde tuvo
grandes afectaciones debido al acumulado
de agua estoy con concepción martínez
ella perdió su vivienda prácticamente
debido a la crecida de este río junto
donde usted habita como pues fue algo
que nunca había había visto
dicen que antes de nada
la vida de antes nadie la gente vieja
pues más adulta dice que nunca había
sucedido esto hasta hoy hasta ustedes
sabían del huracán pero nadie les avisó
que debían evacuar si sabíamos por qué
vamos aquí está en las noticias pero no
otra vez se dicen hacen alarmas pero no
no sucede entonces a sí mismo lo
confiamos esta vez podría mostrarnos los
daños en sus viviendas y cuénteme cómo
fue y a qué hora ustedes se percataron
cómo lograron salir ileso después eso
fue a las 10 de la noche
o cuando era normal se estaba todo
título está inundado
yo solo logré sacar a mis hijos mis tres
tipos
y ya tenía que cuál cuál es el daño si
lo ha cuantificado hasta ahora
bueno aquí es a mí se me llevó todas las
cosas de la cocina todos los
ministrantes
la ropa zapatos la comida todo se me fue
esto fue hace más de 24 horas cómo están
donde están viviendo están en albergues
como esto estamos en casa de mi mamá ahí
estamos y vamos sobreviviendo el
gobierno alguna autoridad ha venido a
brindarles ayuda no
gracias y como concepción hay muchas
familias que no han podido acceder a la
ayuda humanitaria debido a que los
caminos los ríos se han crecido y los
han inhabilitado
nos vamos a estados unidos el país
rebasa las 250.000 muertes y los 11
millones de casos acumulados en medio de
la atención política por el resultado de
las elecciones presidenciales las
hospitalizaciones por el cob y 19
también se incrementaron comparadas con
el mes pasado
los cuerpos sin vida siguen llegando
incluso las diez morgues móviles están
alcanzando su tope tanto así que en el
paso texas los reclusos de las cárceles
fueron contratados para transportar las
pilas de muertos a los hospitales están
llenos han tenido que transferir
pacientes y cerca de cinco mil
trabajadores de la salud adicionales
fueron desplegados en todo el estado
y texas no es la única jurisdicción con
un vertiginoso aumento de casos el virus
se está propagando en los 50 estados la
zona del medio oeste es la más afectada
sobre todo en los estados que siguen a
donald trump pues no se ha reforzado el
uso de tapabocas ni el distanciamiento
social
jacques yo no creo que el virus sea tan
grave
ellos exageran lo agrandan más de lo que
es
como en texas arizona tampoco ha
impuesto un mandato de uso de tapabocas
el gobernador le sugirió a los
residentes utilizarlos pero eso no duró
mucho por el choque de opiniones los que
lo apoyan y los que no han supuesto la
verdad aun algunos quieren un cierre
total y por otro algunos creen que todo
es una farsa
poulter lauren bacall ambos grupos son
muy vocales la mayoría de las personas
no apoyan estas opiniones
con el uso de tapabocas a un politizado
eeuu superó el umbral de las 250.000
muertes por cobo y 19 ahora tiene el
rango de muertes más alto del mundo a lo
largo del país las filas de pruebas de
diagnóstico son largas las últimas dos
semanas los casos se incrementaron en un
79% superando un millón de contagios en
tan sólo seis días
mientras tanto el alcalde de nueva york
bill de blasio anunció ayer el cierre de
las escuelas públicas de la ciudad para
contener el avance de la pandemia y este
jueves la organización mundial de la
salud defendió la necesidad de mantener
abiertas las escuelas durante esta
pandemia del coronavirus es por ello que
enlazamos a nueva york con nuestra
corresponsal mabe en shalam amén buenos
días por allá cuando volverán a abrir
sus puertas las escuelas
muy buenos dias sadam pues de momento
permanecen cerradas de manera indefinida
aunque el alcalde de la ciudad bill de
blasio ya ha dicho que esto es una
decisión temporal hasta que la situación
mejore solo que significa hasta que las
cifras de contagio estén por debajo del
3% que es el máximo que se había marcado
la ciudad y el estado de nueva york para
tomar las decisiones el cierre de
colegio se da casi ocho semanas después
de que hayan reabierto sus puertas y
afectará a cerca de 300.000 alumnos que
a partir de hoy como decías comenzarán
sus estudios de manera remota desde el
departamento de educación de la ciudad
han dicho que están mejores preparados
que la última vez cuando ya hubo algunos
problemas técnicos y han comenzado a
repartir ordenadores y ipads entre los
estudiantes la polémica no se ha hecho
esperar y muchos padres que trabajan y
ya se habían organizado de cara a este
año pues no entiende nada se quejan
porque no entienden por qué las escuelas
públicas porque las privadas continuarán
abiertas han tenido que cerrar sus
puertas mientras que restaurantes y
gimnasios todavía
abiertos porque preocupa mamen
especialmente la situación en estos
momentos
si hablan pues sobre todo porque
recordemos que el nueva york fue el
epicentro inicial de esta pandemia y
parecía que se recuperaba mejor que el
resto de los estados pero en los últimos
días parece que los contagios se han
vuelto a disparar superando el 3 por
ciento que tanto preocupa y también han
aumentado las hospitalizaciones cuando
tan sólo quedan siete días para que se
celebre first and giving así que el
gobernador del estado de nueva york
andrew como está haciendo mucho hincapié
en estos últimos días en que las
familias traten de viajar lo mínimo
posible que esas reuniones no superen a
las diez personas y que utilicen en todo
momento la mascarilla esto alan es un
retroceso en esta ciudad en un momento
como decía que está avanzando y además
ya sabéis que la semana pasada se impuso
este toque de queda a restaurantes y
gimnasios que tienen que cerrar sus
puertas a las 10 de la noche y el
gobernador andrew como ya he dicho que
continúan que si continúan aumentando
los casos las restricciones serán
todavía más duras
gracias por tu reporte mamen sala en
nuestra corresponsal de france 24 de
nueva york y seguimos hablando de la
pandemia y es que hoy qué es
de noviembre les resaltamos estas
noticias sobre las pruebas y la carrera
de las vacunas contra el kobe 19
la segunda fase de pruebas clínicas de
la vacuna de la universidad inglesa de
oxford demuestra que es segura en
personas mayores sanas y provoca una
respuesta inmune según the lancet es
este grupo el que tiene un mayor riesgo
de desarrollar una enfermedad grave se
espera que los datos de la fase 3 se
publiquen para navidad la administración
de medicamentos estadounidense ha
aprobado la primera prueba de
coronavirus que se puede hacer en casa
sólo se podrá utilizar en caso de
emergencia y requerirá prescripción
médica es un test de un solo uso y
tendría un costo mayor a los 40 dólares
la empresa de biotecnología inició un
ensayo de fase 3 para el korona back con
miles de voluntarios principalmente en
brasil la vacuna china que compite con
la de moderna y fisher produce una
rápida respuesta inmunológica y puede
conservarse entre los 2 y los 8 grados
aunque advierten que todavía son
necesarios más estudios
y nos vamos a israel donde el secretario
de estado de eeuu mike pompeo sigue de
visita oficial
pompeo visitó el viñedo desagote situado
en el área industrial israelí de shaar
biniamín entre jerusalén y la ciudad
palestina de ramala desde ahí anunció
que se desplazará este jueves a la
región de los altos del golán territorio
ocupado por israel desde 1967 y
reconocido por eeuu como soberano de
israel el año pasado antes de su nuevo
desplazamiento pompeo defendió el legado
del presidente de donald trump y dijo
que han hecho cosas increíbles en los
acuerdos auspiciados por eeuu en medio
oriente pero que son rechazados por las
autoridades palestinas
hoy tendré la oportunidad de visitar los
altos del golán el simple reconocimiento
de esto como parte israel también fue
una decisión que el presidente camps
tomó que es históricamente importante y
simplemente un reconocimiento de la
realidad ahora un informe constata el
presunto asesinato de 39 civiles afganos
por soldados australianos el oficial
militar de mayor rango de australia dijo
que hay evidencia creíble de que algunos
militares de su país presuntamente
mataron a un grupo de civiles por lo que
soldados australianos de élite serán
investigados sobre presuntos crímenes de
guerra cometidos en afganistán entre
2005 año en que se reforzó la presencia
militar y 2016 cuando se ordenó la
investigación el informe dice que
ninguno de los actos cometidos por los
soldados australianos habrían sido bajo
presión en el calor del combate de
geinfor este vergonzoso historial
incluye supuestos casos en los que
nuevos miembros de la patrulla fueron
obligados a disparar a un prisionero a
fin de lograr la primera muerte de ese
soldado en una práctica atroz conocida
como ensangrenta miento
y clarín en argentina cientos de mujeres
se movilizaron en respaldo a la
despenalización del aborto en el país la
actividad se registró un día después de
que el presidente alberto fernández
enviará al congreso un proyecto de ley
para permitir la interrupción del
embarazo seguro y gratuito en la nación
luis méndez zúrich tienen los detalles
y cientos de mujeres se aglomeraron en
las inmediaciones del congreso argentino
durante la tarde de este miércoles
portando pañuelos verdes o prendas de
vestir de ese color que caracteriza la
lucha por el aborto legal de que
argentinas ofrecieron su respaldo al
presidente alberto fernández quien envió
el parlamento un proyecto de ley para
despenalizar la interrupción voluntaria
del embarazo la iniciativa del ejecutivo
abrió nuevamente un debate que parecía
cerrado en 2018
el tiempo
y creo que este año
para nosotros además de un
reconocimiento de la lucha militante
feminista
por años diversos movimientos en
argentina han exigido un mayor derecho
de las mujeres a decidir sobre sus
cuerpos hace exactamente dos años una
iniciativa similar a la propuesta por
fernández pasó la aprobación de los
diputados pero fue rechazada por el
senado
y hacen una pelea como la que
emprendimos de hondo delante durante
todos estos años
porque la propia
en lo que parece está bien
de la secretaria legal y técnica de la
nación revelan que en el país se
producen entre 370.000 y 520 mil
interrupciones voluntarias del embarazo
por año para el presidente fernández los
derechos reproductivos también son un
problema de salud pública
el presidente interino de perú francisco
sagasti que asumió el cargo el martes
tras la renuncia de manuel merino
presionado por las protestas nombró como
primera ministra violeta bermúdez
abogada constitucionalista para ser la
jefa del gabinete de 18 ministros el
reto de nuevo gabinete y de sagasti que
debe completar el mandato gubernamental
hasta julio de 2021 y antes de celebrar
elecciones el 11 de abril es avisar las
protestas tras más de una semana de
sacudidas políticas con hasta 3
presidentes en ejercicio sin embargo las
protestas parece no detenerse y cientos
de personas volvieron a salir ayer en
lima todos los integrantes del gabinete
de ministros juraron a su cargo - el
ministerio de energía y minas que aún no
se designan
así pues llegamos al final de esta
emisión les agradecemos mucho su
compañía los invitamos a que sigan con
nosotros en france24 ya que se cuide
cuídense mucho del hobbit y cine
[Música]